Jason you said something I think I heard
you say you still had to get your game
up I'm sorry if I'm paraphrasing but
what was it that you felt you were off
about or that you need to improve on and
how have you worked through that hmm for
that role well uh I felt like I was just
a talking head like I think there's a
feeling that matters described where
your there's one part of you that's
outside of yourself it's aware of what
you're doing but then there's another
part which is just there and in that
moment and it almost feels like there's
some deeper part of you that's doing the
work and that's performing the actions
and it's like you're in like a knob
looks like another self and I didn't
have that it's hard to explain you know
I guess I think I think people try to
over intellectualize acting a lot and
you need technique for sure but I think
when you over intellectualize acting and
try to put a lot of specific when I got
to be specific as an actor but when you
try to be fully I'm trying to think the
best way to describe this I think if my
dad has a saying if you can remember
exactly how you did then it probably
wasn't any good because you were
probably too concerned about how you
were doing it rather than just doing it
right there interesting so I God that I
was aware of that that I was not letting
go and just losing myself in that moment
and just I think that takes confidence
and a lot of being in touch with
yourself and who you are do you think
because it mattered so much that was
your first job and you know you're going
to be on set with your dad too so maybe
you wanted to please him but it just
mattered so much it was hard to really
be in the moment that sounds like yeah
and I just think you know as a teenager
you don't really know who you are yet
and you're just starting to figure out
what this whole acting thing is and I
think it's a teenager's a hard time to
be an actor because
when you're a child you're quite free
you know kids they have a lot of
impulses and they don't and I that they
don't censor themselves you know they're
very close to who they are and they I
don't think there is self aware of their
habits or insecure and I think there's a
stereotype that you know that kid actors
aren't good I don't think that's true i
think they're only not good if you try
to make them act or if you'd write them
as little adults because kids are so
they're so spontaneous and they're so
impulsive and they're so connected to
their body and who they are if you ever
watch the audition video for et the kid
who plays Elliot it Steven Spielberg's
in a room with him and that's how you
direct a child actor if you watch that
that video officer looked out of isn't
on YouTube mm-hmm oh great yeah that
sounds good what was it the way
Spielberg directed him that's
fascinating uh it's been a while since
I've seen it he didn't try to make him
give these results he just said you know
like this is what's happening to you and
you know your friend they're gonna take
him away you just talk to him like a kid
you just understood what kids want you
know rather than trying to tell he
wasn't telling him like be cute like you
know be the angry or like be he was just
he was just telling them like this is
what's happening to your friend you know
and if they take him away then you won't
have your friend anymore and you know
justice just give it to me and like I
think something like that I know that's
just
you